So here we have the Netherlands. Over here we have the land.
Here's the sea and you can see that the sea levels a bit higher than the level of the land.
We have this dike preventing the sea from overtaking the land
and of course we have this beautiful little wind mill powering this Archimedes' screw.
Now seems like this is going to be a very difficult task. We have a lot water to move.
To get you starting to think about just how difficult this task could be,
I want you to think about this question.
What two factors contribute most to the difficulty of this task?
So this windmill has a lot of work to do, what two factors contribute most?
Maybe the total weight of water or the total amount of water that we have to lift.
Maybe the cleanliness of the water is important.
Maybe it's the distance, which I've labeled here as d, that we have to lift the water
or maybe the temperature of the water
is the most important thing or one of the most two most important thing.
I want you to choose the best two answers here and then we can talk about that.